on this hill overlooking the city of set
in the South of France you'll find the
home of Eric Ben Sayid spacious windows
graced the entire facade and suggest
that there's much to be discovered
inside the Sam stone framing the
extension came from the very ground on
which the IT manager had his house built
hi module good morning welcome in said
welcome in my in my house that's doing
[Music]
the entrance leads right into the
open-concept living area covering 120
square meters it functions as a sitting
room kitchen dining room and lounge this
house is a mix of travel stories and
when I travel you you have a lot of
feelings a lot of emotion a lot of
sensibilities and I wanted to to to put
all of these feelings and all of these
vibes inside in one house in one place
the businessman had the house built to
his specifications four years ago he's
furnished the living room with design
classics like this Charles Eames Lounge
Chair from 1956 and modern sofas from
here there's a clear view of the port
city of set and the Mediterranean
[Music]
in this region we have seen almost over
here so the house has to be on the same
waves so I wanted to have in this house
a Spanish spirit and because Eric bin
Saeed is a fan of the Spanish island of
Ibiza he decorated the bedrooms on the
upper floor giving them a typical Island
style look bright colors give the place
a real holiday feel the room is one of
the place you spend a lot of time and
the colour blue color mix with the Sun
make make you happy thank you the
interior design is a mix of styles retro
accessories design classics and modern
furniture while purists might not
approve this resident clearly feels very
much at home here
[Music]
Ben Saeed also has a passion for
recycled materials in the bathroom old
railway ties serve as a countertop and
the old wood planks constituting the
dining room table were once part of an
Indonesian fishing vessel during one of
my travel in Indonesia I saw in one of
many free market a guy who has made
fishing Fisher boat by rod by rug for
fishermen and they put all the all the
boat and make a table I say it's it's
it's wonderful for my house the house
also has a wine cellar with a small bar
the color scheme of the retro look
wallpaper harmonizes with the British
colonial style leather armchairs a table
made from recycled wooden pallets
provides the finishing touch this table
is a part of my life he's one of my pets
because it follows me during all my
student life and we used to have drink
we used to have a convivial party he
still has parties around that table
today except nowadays the wine is a bit
more expensive it's a home full of
memories and atmosphere so I really
appreciate you've Anu here and I tell
you goodbye and let's meet together next
time bye bye Eric Ben Syed and his house
in set a personal home inspired by very
personal experiences